it might seem strange but gravity is a
lot weaker than the other basic forces
of nature let's take a look at this
chart it shows how the strength of each
fundamental Force changes when the
energy increases or the distance over
which the force operates decreases we've
only been able to study these forces at
relatively low energies but we can guess
what might happen at higher energies and
when we do we find a point where the
electromagnetic weak and strong forces
all become equally powerful we call this
unification however gravity seems to
relate to this party its path to
unification appears to be much further
out this is where the elusive Theory of
Everything comes into play but what if
some of the gravitational force escaped
into for example a fourth spatial
dimension in that case its strength
could reduce more quickly and it might
reach unification with the other three
forces earlier